i started falling into this
pattern of just doing trends seeing what
was you know hot and just jumping on it
yeah i just wasn't happy so
i was like i'm going to make myself
happy and i'm going to do
stuff that you know i didn't think i'd
ever wanted to do
[Music]
as a kid i was very introverted i was
very quiet i kept to myself
and i kind of still am but i guess i'm a
lot more
out of my show whenever i'm on camera my
parents were very strict
nigerian african parents they were
always like education is key
and it is key but you know my focus is
always
on other things i think if they let me
do my thing
i probably would have stayed in
education
which is the funniest thing like i would
have wanted to learn and i would have
wanted to
uh study but because my parents were so
strict and forced me to do certain
things i i've always been a person that
does the opposite of what someone tells
me to do
so i was about 11 when i started my
first youtube channel
i think i uploaded family guy and
that got copyright copyright strikes so
i do remember one of my first content
was a game called june 2000 or june 3000
this old game that i was obsessed with i
loved it
and it actually did really well and i
mean i say lord it was like
10 20 people but like it was still like
a lot of people to me but uh
i think i gave that channel to my bro
and made another channel which everyone
knows now ksl and gwt
do you think that anyone you knew back
then could have known
where you would end up i didn't think
i'd end up where
i am today like let's be honest i've
done quite a lot in my
in my lifetime that i didn't think i'd
ever be able to do
i didn't think i'd ever have a song with
craig david i didn't think i'd ever have
a song with
rick ross i didn't think i'd ever be in
a boxing match in a pro
boxing fight you know i'd have a group
it's called the side memo we're making
youtube videos weekly like i didn't
think a lot of things
and i know 100 know that all the people
in school did not expect where i'm at
today
uh and it's still crazy even to this day
i still get
messages on my facebook saying you know
like
it's crazy where you are right now like
i never thought that you'd be this type
of person
you've talked in previous interviews
about how like 2017 was almost the year
things
turned yeah what changed
i started falling into this
pattern of just doing what you know
people wanted to see just doing trends
seeing what was
you know hot and just jumping on it and
i wasn't really making content i wanted
to make
personally i don't like saying that i
was depressed i
i kind of just got to porn i was like
wow man i'm just
i'm just not happy i'm just not
happy with like what i'm doing i'm just
not happy where i'm at
i deleted a load of videos
delete all my tweets delete all my
instagram pictures
i was like i'm going to make myself
happy and i'm going to do
stuff that you know i didn't think i'd
ever wanted to do
so i went and traveled i really you know
found myself i really
um you know i had fun i
i didn't worry about numbers i wasn't
looking at stats i wasn't obsessed with
my phone
being able to now come back in a better
uh state of mind is just so important
in 2017 as well yeah yeah so it starts
with um
with joe weller um when that
first came about did you ever imagine it
was going to be as big as it was
uh no i know i never thought the trouble
if i was gonna be as big as it was
i trained like my whole life depended on
that fight
and it was literally every day i trained
every single day i would go on runs
every day i was doing
you know weights every day i was just
doing something
to improve my body i sacrificed
you know making youtube videos i
sacrificed doing a lot of things
and my whole focus was just on that
fight
i kind of knew that i had won because it
was
the similar zen that i was in
when i was fighting logan paul in the
pro boxing fight
where i was there like i've worked for
this
i'm ready you're not ready to fight me
right now
the first logan paul fight i was kind of
i was a bit too confident i was a bit
too
overconfident and i thought oh i've got
this it's logan paul he hasn't really
boxed
i i got a draw but you know i just
didn't feel happy with that
so i made sure to rectify in the second
flight after about a week
that's when it settled in and that's
when i woke up and went
holy [ __ ] i did that
i looked back at the video i looked at
uh
the whole like footage of me walking
into the ring the
thousands of people at the la staple
center
um you know the fight i looked to
everything and i went jesus
christ man that was wild you obviously
had beef with
both jeweller and logan paul yeah and
luke's brother
and what was your view of them then
really and how do you view them all
night
um well i've always hate jake paul i i
think he's a [ __ ]
i think the videos he makes shows he's a
[ __ ]
but i think with logan at least his
videos were
somewhat entertaining with joe weller
you know it's
weird because we were we were friends uh
and then we kind of turned into enemies
because of this fight
you can never really be true friends
after something like that
i just don't think it can ever ever
happen
maybe if you fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but the
idea of
being friends with someone that has
beaten you
it's a hard thing for your head to
compute and i think that's why me and
joe
will never ever be true friends again
and why me and logan will never be
friends
and why me and jake will never be
friends
music has always just been a hobby of
mine but
you know youtube well i mean youtube was
also a hobby
and it kind of just turned into
something that i made money from
and the same is just happening with
music you know the better i'm getting
with music
the more money i'm starting to make i'm
kind of now at a point where
i'm able to really find my sound make
good music and i'm happy with the music
that i'm producing
and now i can just put more stuff out
put more content out and
you know work with people that i never
thought i'd be able to work with and
really you know come in with
bangers man i remember when i went to
my first uh concert it was a watch the
throne
kanye west and jay-z and
i was there with um a few of my
schoolmates
ride the backside connie was just like a
little speck saying with jc i remember
they're on like these huge
box platforms and uh i was watching it
and i was like
one day i'm gonna do this one day i'm
gonna perform in front of
hundreds of thousands or thousands of
people i don't know how
and how i'm gonna do it but one day i'm
gonna do it
i'm proud of the fact that my parents
were proud of me
with the direction i've gone in
i just never really thought they would
be uh
a hundred percent with what i'm doing
but you know they're
100 with me now and you know they've
been 100 with me
for a long time i don't even look at
numbers anymore man like
yeah every now and then i go oh yeah
look i've got this many millions
subscribers for me what's important is
just making content
that people just enjoy and making music
that people just
enjoy and punching people in the face
and letting them enjoy that
so i don't want to just be seen as one
thing i like being
seen as a range of things when it comes
to
music or the boxing or youtube you know
i'm able to just
be quite fluid with what i want to do
the idea of
you know having a youtube um
having a youtube audience and having a
music audience and having a boxing
audience and then being able to gel that
together having you know
mainstream success and all this and all
of that you know i'm able to
really just come home and just
make whatever i want do whatever i want
and
build a lot of hype around it and
essentially like
if i make good if i make it good if i
make a good product
it will fly i'm not a person i was just
born with
you know all these skills i've just
worked hard
and you know it's crazy what hard work
can get
you
[Music]
now 50 feet 40 feet
30 feet 20 feet all the time looking
checking looking and at 20 feet i got
onto the left hand
wing clambering over that door lip
and then i stood onto the wing and was
able to stand on the wing momentarily